buonasera a tutti io questa sera vi
parlerò appunto di questa tematica delle
piccole e medie imprese online e delle
opportunità che hanno di crescita ma per
farlo partirei da un'esperienza comune
vi è mai capitato di andare a cena da un
amico parlare con un collega di lavoro e
sentirlo entusiasta di un prodotto o di
un servizio e di sentire che la realtà
che aveva creato quel prodotto quel
servizio era in realtà una piccola
realtà di eccellenza
avete magazine ato il dato nella vostra
mente siete tornati a casa
avete continuato con la vostra vita e un
giorno vi siete trovati nella condizione
di dire ma quella volta avevo visto
quella cosa così bella
e allora avete provato a cercarla
siete entrati in un motore di ricerca
con un'idea più chiara di cosa stavate
cercando e spesso non avete trovato la
risposta che vi aspettavate nelle
trovate di diverse non siete magari
riusciti a identificare quell azienda o
quel prodotto che così bene vi aveva
impressionato
questo in realtà è molto più frequente
di quanto si possa immaginare perché
solo un'azienda su tre in questo momento
per quanto riguarda le piccole e medie
imprese è dotata di un sito internet è
solo una su otto ha pensato di poter
proporre i propri servizi ai propri
prodotti online tramite un e commerce
questo di fatto è un grosso problema
diciamo che è un'occasione persa si sono
trovati nella situazione di non riuscire
ad ottimizzare la propria immagine
online e sono rimasti per lo più
delle aziende sconosciute o tutt'al più
dei numeri di telefono e degli indirizzi
se hanno avuto la fortuna di essere
almeno su pagine gialle questa
situazione è una situazione di partenza
che credo che ciascuno abbia vissuto in
realtà io ho pensato e lo propongo anche
i miei clienti quotidianamente a una
semplice strategia perché in sostanza
non esistere o esistere solo come
indirizzo e numero di telefono da una
pessima impressione e non c'è una
seconda possibilità per dare una buona
impressione e quindi in realtà tutti noi
valutiamo tramite le apparenze e se non
abbiamo avuto modo di trovare un
riscontro nine probabilmente penseremo
che quel prodotto che l'azienda non
esiste più e non ci preoccuperemo di
cercarla o di raggiungerla quindi
citando dei punti molto molto semplice
se io dovessi parlare una piccola media
impresa le direi crea un tuo sito web
l'immagine che tu proponi di te stesso
come azienda è fondamentale deve essere
una cosa semplice deve essere alla
portata di tutti non deve essere in un
primo momento un sito dove ci sono
concetti particolarmente astrusi o
immagini particolarmente complesse mette
in evidenza i tuoi prodotti come farebbe
chiunque apre un negozio non penserebbe
solo a dove aprirlo ma penserebbe anche
a cosa mettere in vetrina
perché può capitare che qualcuno passi
davanti anche per caso anche perché
tramite un gioco di parole ai motori di
ricerca approda su quel sito e se non
riesce a capire effettivamente di cosa
si sta parlando e cosa si sta proponendo
probabilmente ne esce subito da cui
fatti trovare da chi ti cerca capisci
chi può avere bisogno del tuo prodotto o
del tuo servizio con dvd e interagisci
spesso un altro problema grosso che si
riscontra che anche avendo un sito
internet è il classico sito internet
vetrina
in quell azienda smette dopo averlo
costruito di raccontare cosa sta facendo
verso cosa si sta muovendo
quali sono i progetti su cui sta
lavorando e questo inevitabilmente porta
a dare l'idea di un senso di stantio di
non innovativo una strategia ben
definita il primo passo verso il
successo quindi io devo conoscere le mie
eccellenze e devo di sicuro proporle a
chi ne sta cercando la presenza sul web
è quindi oggi un paradigma fondamentale
per essere trovati e per riuscire ad
aumentare la propria visibilità questo
punto le definizioni non sempre contano
fatti vedere è volutamente inserito per
dire che a volte le aziende soprattutto
in veneto hanno paura di uscire allo
scoperto perché dicono io faccio bene
una cosa ma ne faccio solo una
ho paura di espormi perché mi trovo a
competere con chi fa tutta la filiera fa
tantissime parti
questo è sbagliato se c'è la certezza di
avere un eccellenza di avere un punto di
vantaggio competitivo questo va
valorizzato assolutamente è poi
importante usare collega correttamente i
blog i social
oltre al fatto che rendono molto più
visibile danno appunto quel senso di
vitalità ed hanno la possibilità di
interagire con delle persone che trovano
il prodotto o il servizio che l'azienda
sta proponendo e addirittura possono
dare dei feedback su quello che sono le
loro desiderate i loro sogni i loro
pensieri pensa differente le idee già
vista e quello che è già stato proposto
per anni anche se è un background
fondamentale dell'azienda
probabilmente non è più sufficiente come
si diceva poc'anzi probabilmente il
miglior modo per riuscire a
predisporre un futuro è appunto pensare
a un nuovo sistema per veicolare il
proprio prodotto o per la creazione di
nuovi prodotti
infine l'e commerce dove applicabile
anche al mercato di riferimento perché
spesso un mercato che ha solo locale o
tuttalpiù regionale può essere veicolato
a livello italiano europeo o anche oltre
tramite questo tipo di strumento le
piccole e medie imprese in italia
assicurano da 80 per cento
dell'occupazione in e micro imprese sono
95 per cento del totale quelle che hanno
creduto nel web e hanno cominciato a
vendere online stanno già spostando una
quota significativa e sviluppando ancor
meglio una quota significativa del loro
fatturato nel canale online e quindi è
importante capire che il web cambia le
regole del gioco
il valore creato da un'azienda in
relazione alla qualità di prodotto e di
processo è un tema che deve restare ma
di qui in poi
di qui in avanti e come sta avvenendo
già altrove le dimensioni aziendali non
necessariamente devono essere
proporzionali al valore creato e con
questo mi ricollego al concetto del
nelle reti di impresa che è stato
poc'anzi citato dal precedente relatore
perché anch'io faccio parte di una
piccola impresa
ho capito che mi mancavano delle
componenti delle parti e mi sono
integrato in un sistema che qui in
padova il talent garden e quindi ho
trovato altre piccole imprese come me
che avevano delle eccellenze in delle
singole parti e hanno avuto e stanno
sviluppando delle idee innovative e da
questa contaminazione secondo me
c'è la possibilità di creare dei concept
reali e digitali che possono sviluppare
in futuro grazie